feature-length films get most of the
glory but this year's nominees in the
short film categories proved the wisdom
of the old adage I would have made it
shorter if I only have the time they had
the time and used it brilliantly proving
that an inspiring amount of genius and
artistry can be delivered in 40 minutes
or less here are the nominees for Best
live action short film a candle aerial
that wasn't me Esteban Crispo Ivanka did
you felt just before losing everything
Xavi a legume and Alexandra Carver's
helium Anders Walter and Kim Magnussen
Pizza akamonkai Quijote do I have to
take care of everything
Salma girls women and Pearce akka sorry
the Voorman problem Marc Gill and
Baldwin Lee and the Oscar goes to helium
and is Walter and Kim Magnussen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow this is crazy
I want to thank the Academy and I want
to thank the the short brands for
keeping this category in the show it's
amazing it's amazing window for new
talents to show their film I want to
thank an amazing cast a fantastic crew
who did this film for no money at all
who just showed up and I'm fell in love
with this this film and I want to thank
my family I want to thank my my
beautiful wife Anna I'm a beautiful
daughter Clara and I want to thank two
great producers who was always behind me
one is TV mechanism and the other one is
his son and this is this guy key
mechanism I just want to take a quick
note and thank everybody who's keep on
making these shorts our fellow nominees
thank you congratulations to all and
then I would like to thank my wife
Rebecca my four kids and for my mother
this is for you I know you're watching
at home sick so this is for your mom
[Music]
[Applause]